in this video we'll be talking about
gaussian disease
gauche disease was discovered by Philip
gauche in 1882's and this is a rare
genetic disorder that belongs to the
group of conditions called lysosomal
storage Disorder so obviously the
lysosome is involved and in the lysosome
there is a buildup of glucose
cerebrosite
and glucose cerebrosite builds up
because the enzyme that breaks down
glucosabrocyte is kind of non-functional
in this disease
glucose cerebrosidase is the enzyme that
breaks down glucose cerebrosite and this
is encoded by the gene GBA which is
located in the chromosome 1. in this
disease due to a mutation the gene
doesn't produce optimally the glucose
cerebrosidase so the functional glucose
cerebrosidase enzyme is not present in
general the glucosal brosidase enzyme
breakdown glucose cerebrocyte into
glucose and ceramides so obviously this
breakdown doesn't happen
due to this gene mutation
and that's the key cause of this
particular gauche's disease
when it comes to inheritance pattern
this is an autosomal recessive pattern
of inheritance that means if both
parents are carrier that means one
allele in the parents are faulty then
there is a 25 percent of the chance that
the next in next generation one of the
child out of four would be affected so
there is a 25 chance
now gauche's disease can be classified
into type 1 type 2 and type 3. in case
of type 1 which is the most common form
and it primarily affects the bones liver
and the spleen
in this case hepatospholino Mega Lee or
enlarged spleen or liver is quite common
along with fatigue and bone pain
the neurological symptoms are typically
absent in this case
now in type 2 most severe forms of most
severe symptoms appear from the central
nervous system so it's kind of like
involved the central nervous system
then the symptoms include severe brain
damage developmental regression seizures
and even neurological issues are there
then type 3 has a severity in between
type 1 and type 2. and it involves both
visceral organs and neurological
components
let's talk about the pathology of
gaussian's disease
so generally every cell type have
glucose cerebroside as a glycolipid
Incorporated in their membrane
so generally when the cells get old and
die due to some reason
sometimes macrophages of the immune
cells that take up these debris and
clear up them by phagocytosis
so inside the macrophages there are
lysosomes which can break down the
glycolipids that means the spially the
glucose cerebrocyte present in in the
membrane
so overall glucose cerebrocide is broken
down into the respective catabolite
catabolic products with the help of
glucose erebrosy days
but in case of gauche's disease the
glucose cerebrosidase is faulty that
means the breakdown doesn't happen
and thereby there is a buildup of
glucose cerebrosite inside the lysosome
so obviously when the fat the fatty
products build up inside the lysosome
this gives them macrophages a different
appearance it's kind of like a tissue
paper crumpled tissue paper like
appearance and that is very
characteristics of gauche's disease
and these are known as gaussian cells
under microscopic examination anybody
can identify this kind of gaussian cells
which are pretty characteristics of this
disease
now let's talk about what these gaucher
cells can actually do these gaussian
cells are actually found in the bone
marrow liver and the spleen eventually
it leads to an enlargement of the spleen
and the liver
also the gaussian cells can secrete
lysosomal enzymes and pro-inflammatory
cytokines which can evoke inflammation
and tissue scurring specially is cutting
in the liver and spleen might lead to
several metabolic defects
one of that is basically severe bone
marrow fibrosis which lead to reduction
in the RBC production that might lead to
anemia development of fatigue Etc
also there is a reduced blood flow
seen in the bone in the bone that lead
to bone crisis and eventually might lead
to osteoporosis
now other symptoms of type 1 gaucher
disease includes hepatosplenomegaly
so not only there is a scarring in the
liver but also in the spleen there are
entrapped
thrombocytes and that lead to
thrombocytopenia
since the thrombocytes are less
the bruising is more frequent and there
are more chances of bruising and
bleeding
now here comes the gaussian disease type
2. it has all the neurological symptoms
generally in type 1 the neurological
symptoms are not prevalent
but in case of type 2 acute neuropathic
which is also known as acute neuropathic
kosher disease there are many
neurological symptoms
and it generally happens in the early
stage of the life glucose cerebrocyte
can actually be toxic for the brain
and it leads to loss of motor skill
decreased muscle tone muscle spasms
trouble in swallowing generally the
babies die
because they can't get feeding properly
and sometimes they have swallowing
difficulty and food get stuck in their
lung so these are the problems
and the death happens within the first
few years of the life
koshit is a Type 3 is a kind of like
intermediately severe compared to the
type 2 and it's a little bit more severe
compared to type 1. and this in this
case the symptoms appear in the second
decade of the life so it's a late onset
the neurological symptoms are present
but their onset is slow one of the most
prevalent symptoms that is found in
kosher disease type 3 is the recurrent
seizures
so here comes the diagnosis of the
gaussians disease so glucose cerebrosity
is activity from patient's Serum is one
of the diagnostic tests then genetic
test genetic testing looking for the GBA
gene mutation is kind of like a very
much confirmatory
and the clinicians generally try to look
at the patient's symptom and try to get
a
overall idea about this disease
progression
there is no cure for this this
particular disease but enzyme
replacement therapy where artificial
glucose erebrosidase is provided can
improvise the situation then substrate
reduction therapy that means medications
or drugs that can basically reduce the
production of glucosaribrocyte can also
be useful and apart from all of these
the symptoms that that are gener that
are associated with disease can be
managed properly with supportive care
and that's the treatment options for
this disease so I hope this was useful
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can follow us on Facebook
and Instagram links are provided in
description support us using super
thanks see you in next video
[Music]